thank you for calling Vantage lightbulb
time they brighten up your day you can
start by telling me why I've got an
entire Christmas tree that won't light
up so your lights are properly plugged
into an electrical outlet Oh an
electrical outlet all this time I had
them plugged into my dogs okay my job
lots of people hate their job man I
failed the bar for the second time which
means I got to keep working at the call
center I would think that the lucky few
who have jobs would be bending over with
gratitude are you bending drew I get
fired for naked pictures you are
suspended indefinitely
I need your wings and it humped by a dog
in a mask I was just I don't know I was
humped just yet a black face mask okay
he had a mask not face get it right
uh-huh
tell me again why you didn't get her
number
oh I know exactly where I find her star
maker Academy I'm the only person in
this town who can take you right to the
top baby you so amazing babe like like
your boobs are heaving and finicky you
go here now yeah but a little boy like
you do with a woman like me now look at
me and say chili powder job she's gonna
need a new pilot
I could be your copilot drew we can fly
her into some international territory
you feel me
what does that even mean I need
something strange laughing uh do you
have a name Oh jelly I feel like I was
written hard and put away wet
Nicky you're blowing everybody went stay
in the moment
hey get up there oh you wimp
tell me to let you go or I'll hold you
like this all day will they little
handicapped boys who say no parks what
no I'm just helping you so I couldn't go
inside and blow them away
you know jiu-jitsu
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Nancy were you able to secure any
details I already told you get a black
face mass of the mass
[Music]
you